now as for James Shaw jr. he was grazed
by a bullet in his arm his hand was also
burned when he grabbed a hot barrel of
the ar-15 everyone here is calling him a
hero but he's uncomfortable that label
was the first time you realized that
something was wrong when I saw the
probably the third shot third or fourth
shot and I saw the Waffle House staff go
like this like they literally dropped in
separate and then I turn around I saw a
guy on the ground and then I was like oh
my so what did you do I grabbed him and
I grabbed the gun and started hitting
and punching and doing anything I could
to get the gun ajar just kind of grabbed
it from I lifted it real high not just
tossed it over the counter and what was
everybody else doing ducking hiding for
cover and I can't blame anybody I can't
blame anybody for not helping me people
calling you a hero you know you save
lives in there right you don't see
yourself as a hero not only I think I
want to be here I think I just want to
be James and James used what he had to
free himself and in Anna miss the
freedom himself he saved you know people
so Shaw who's a native of Nashville just
wishes he got to the gunman faster as
for the manhunt for Reinking the primary
focus is for a to square mile radius of
this Waffle House John Mark thanks James
Shaw I want James Shaw around when
something happens not just courage
humility and what he said to John that
he doesn't blame anyone
thank you very much James Shaw jr. but
I'm thinking about mr.rai king's father
he certainly has some explaining to do
and I saw an interview with James Shaw
jr. saying he has a four-year-old
daughter and he kept thinking about her
- yeah as we said it's motivation if I
was going to die he was going to have to
work for it and in the afterwards he
said he wanted to get in touch with the
families of the victims make sure they
were okay
Thank You mr. Shaw I was trying